[Música]
que se les viene a la mente cuando
escuchan términos como deforestación
calentamiento global derrame de petróleo
crisis climática o desastre ecológico
estoy seguro que la gran mayoría de
nosotros se nos vienen a la mente
imágenes que hemos visto en la
televisión o en internet imágenes de
bosques en llamas de cosechas arrasadas
por la sequía de ríos contaminados con
petróleo de nevados derritiéndose y tal
vez no mucho más pero seamos honestos si
les decimos así no más esas palabras no
sonarán como abstractas como medio hacía
cierto como a informe de ong oa tratados
académicos superespecializado es por eso
que en el periodismo sobre todo aquel
que trata de temas medioambientales es
súper importante aterrizar esos términos
en historias que emocionen a la gente
historias que nos perturben y nos hagan
pensar en cuáles
el impacto que tienen nuestras
decisiones en la naturaleza y la vida de
los demás y en qué rayos estamos
haciendo como sociedad
yo soy periodista y sobre todo dedicado
a mi carrera a escribir y editar
crónicas es decir relatos que parecen
cuentos pero que son reales
y pues durante los últimos años he
venido escribiendo historias sobre
conflictos sociales y ambientales que
suceden en las montañas y en las selvas
del perú historias de hombres y mujeres
indígenas que libran batallas para
impedir que su vida y su cultura no sean
aplastadas por el poder de una empresa
responsable de una mafia o de un mal
gobierno que las trata como si no fueran
ciudadanos
son historias que muchas veces ignoramos
o pasamos por alto porque la sentimos
ajenas a nosotros
y cuando los periodistas nos atrevemos a
contar esas historias a veces nos
limitamos a dar cifras llenos de mapas y
estadísticas sin ofrecerle al lector la
historia completa
sin intentar comprender cómo y por qué
la vida de aquel hombre o de aquella
mujer es transformada para siempre por
la contaminación de su río o la
destrucción del bosque que su hogar
un periodista fracasa cuando se olvida
de la vida de la gente
les doy un ejemplo supongamos que ahora
mismo decidido a escribir una historia
poderosa sobre cómo los incendios
forestales están acabando con el pulmón
del mundo
supongamos que ahora decidió escribir
algo como esto
la deforestación de la amazonía se ve
agravada por una oleada de incendios
nunca visto de los 72 mil 843 focos de
incendio que sufrió brasil a inicio de
2019 más de la mitad de ellos han
afectado a la amazonía el número de
focos de fuego en lo que va de este año
es en un 83 por ciento superior al del
mismo periodo de 2018 según datos
oficiales
puede imaginar que quien lea ese párrafo
que acabo de escribir piense uy qué
terrible qué horror y medio minuto
después cierre el diario
cierre la computadora y saque a pasear a
su perro le debe de comer al gato se
ponga a ver instagram en el celular o
ver vídeos chistosos en youtube se
recordar ni media frase de lo que acaba
de leer por una razón muy simple
porque nada de todo eso que ha leído le
ha hecho pensar esto tiene que ver
conmigo
en periodismo por supuesto que las
estadísticas importan por supuesto que
los detalles técnicos y los datos
importan pero de poco sirve hacer
exhaustivas investigaciones acumular
cientos de datos serios y precisos si
esos datos no tienen alma si esos datos
no nos mueven un pelo
si esos datos no nos paralizan y nos
obligan a pensar en cuál es el rol que
cumplimos en esa realidad
hace unos años yo viajé hasta más zonas
la región donde viven los awajún
una de las 51 naciones amazónicas que
existen y que habitan la selva de perú
viajé hasta allí para contar lo que por
esos días la prensa llamaba la peor
catástrofe ambiental de la última década
eran comienzos de 2016 cuando en la
comunidad de nazaret una enorme tubería
que tiene casi medio siglo de antigüedad
se rompió y derramó unos 500.000 litros
de petróleo en el valle como se vaciarán
media piscina olímpica de combustible
negro y espeso en el río donde decenas
de familias pescan y se bañan
un hecho terrible ocasionado por una
corrosión en el oleoducto norperuano
imaginen ustedes es como una enorme
serpiente de acero que se extiende desde
la profundidad de la selva hasta la
costa y que transporta el petróleo que
consumimos en las ciudades
pero de todo eso que les estoy contando
lo que más lo que más me impactó fue ver
una fotografía que se viralizó por esos
días en facebook
una foto donde hay un niño que tiene de
negro manchados la cara los brazos las
piernas el niño parece sonreír mientras
se está cargando un balde con petróleo
esa foto que muchos de nosotros
podríamos ver y olvidar fue la que a mí
me impulsó a contar esta historia no
solamente porque la foto era una prueba
de que la empresa petroperú había
convocado a varios vecinos awajún entre
ellos más de 50 niños para que acudieran
al río a recoger petróleo a cambio de un
pago
sino porque esa foto también es una
muestra de cómo muchas veces los medios
y la sociedad
solemos retratar a las víctimas de este
tipo de tragedias personas sin nombre
personas de quien no se sabe casi nada y
que solamente nos acordamos de ellas
cuando les ocurren calamidades
yo quería contar la historia esta
tragedia ambiental a través de la vida
de este niño
quería que el lector conociera las vidas
humanas detrás de ese hecho quería
transmitir el poder el peso de esa
tierra arrasada y de pensar como hubo
quienes vieron en esa tragedia ambiental
una forma insólita de progreso
entonces tomé un bus
viaje 23 horas desde lima hasta esa
selva y allí durante tres meses y en
distintos viajes entrevisté a 63
personas entre vecinos awajún
autoridades ingenieros enfermeras
obreros para poder construir esta
crónica que decidí empezar así
si dios pudiera concederle un deseo
osman cuñas y niño bajo un pediría un
smartphone o una pelota de fútbol o
cambiar sus chancletas de plástico por
unas zapatillas o fluorescentes aunque
si lo piensa mejor pediría una casa de
cemento y ladrillo como las que una vez
vio en lima más resistentes a las
tormentas que las cabañas de madera y
techo de hojas que abundan en nazaret
por eso os mandé 11 años flaquito como
un cable piensa mudarse a la capital
para estudiar arquitectura tener una
esposa y un solo hijo pues sabe que
criar tres o cuatro o cinco como es
habitual en su aldea supone pasar hambre
y necesidad eso le ha dicho papá a un
profesor jubilado que alimenta cinco
bocas con su pensión mensual de 400
soles y la mitad del salario mínimo el
padre prefiere que osman sea ingeniero
químico para que sepa todo sobre el
petróleo y así le vaya mejor que a él
porque desde que una enorme tubería rota
derramó unos 500.000 litros de este
combustible aquí en este pedazo de
bosque húmedo y montañoso de amazonas la
segunda región más empobrecida del país
algunos adultos dicen que un mes
limpiando el petróleo del río
siete veces más que un mes cultivando la
tierra aunque teman estar envenenados
recuerdo
que a pesar del profundo miedo que
sentían muchos vecinos abajo me contaron
que con el pago de petroperú pudieron
cambiar sus cabañas de madera por casas
de cemento otros pudieron operarse de
algunas dolencias otros se compraron
mototaxis otros incluso enviaron a sus
hijos a escuelas en la ciudad nunca
habían ganado tanto
austan también le ofrecieron un pago por
recoger el petróleo me acuerdo que
cuando lo conocí yo le pregunté qué
quería comprarse con esa plata y me dijo
un smartphone un celular para jugar ese
videojuego famoso que se llama plantas
versus zombies
seguramente alguno de ustedes tiene un
primo un sobrino un hijo que tiene esa
edad la edad de osman
qué tiene que hacer ese pino y se dijo
este sobrino para tener un celular
la historia de hoy no me hizo pensar en
cómo muchas veces no tenemos idea del
costo
que otros pagan para poder sostener la
vida cómoda que tenemos
se los pongo así
el periodismo muchas veces muestra que
ese costo no se traduce en dinero sino
que se traduce en vidas destruidas
imaginen esto imaginen que un tubo de
gas o de combustible se rompe muy cerca
del parque del olivar un domingo por la
tarde no hay familias caminando paseando
cómo reaccionaría cómo reaccionaría las
autoridades y la prensa cómo
reaccionaría las autoridades la prensa
si eso pasa en uno de los parques de los
distritos más exclusivos de lima
sería un escándalo
pero solamente en el 2016 ocurrieron 14
derrames de petróleo en la selva peruana
y eso muchas veces no parece ser un
asunto nuestro pruebas toxicológicas
demuestran que hoy
osman y 24 niños de su comunidad
tienen la sangre contaminada con plomo
cadmio arsénico mercurio elementos
tóxicos
que según la organización mundial de la
salud dañan el sistema nervioso en la
adultez podrán causar la scan ser eso
demostraron las pruebas toxicológicas
realizadas después del derrame
pero poco nada se ha hecho hasta ahora
para resolver esa emergencia
yo les pregunto
porque las historias de los peruanos
awajún no nos tocan igual que las
historias de los peruanos que viven en
lima por eso quise mostrar que lo que le
pasó a guzmán ya su familia una tragedia
que solemos pensar ajena tiene que ver
con nosotros con las pequeñas decisiones
que tomamos en la casa en el
supermercado o la oficina
alguien aquí en este auditorio podría
pensar que estoy exagerando y
precisamente por eso es que decidí
escribir esto
cuando osman cuñas y sus tres hermanos
llegaron al río contaminado vieron niños
madres embarazadas abuelas y muchachos
sumergidos en el agua o montados en
canoas juntando el petróleo en baldes y
botellas de plástico
el mismo río donde solían bañarse y
construir castillos de barro en sus
orillas donde había aprendido a nadar y
a pescar son garo sivok y chicos ahora
emanaba un olor metálico que les daba
náuseas les picaba la garganta los ojos
les lloraban ruiz ser su hermano de
cuatro años se rindió primero luego omar
de siete ina y su hermana de 14
sumergido en la corriente osman decidió
quedarse hasta llenar su balde ignorando
que ese líquido inflamable que se pegaba
a sus manos es el que permite que
funcione en las ciudades
apenas prestamos atención al petróleo
salvo por el olor acre que flota en la
estación de servicio cuando llenamos el
tanque del auto con dicen pero el
petróleo no es algo que podamos apartar
de nosotros alejándonos del surtidor
mientras no tratamos la nariz
gracias al petróleo ya las industrias
derivadas de él durante el último siglo
hemos construido nuestro sistema de vida
basándonos en su poder calentar nuestros
edificios y hacer funcionar nuestras
máquinas y vehículos pensemos en una
fábrica de televisores o el avión que
tomamos para salir de vacaciones consume
el 84 por ciento del petróleo que se
extrae anualmente en el mundo
el 16% restante se transforma en insumos
para fabricar millones de cosas
sin el oro negro y esa alquimia moderna
llamada petroquímica sería imposible
mascar un chicle o conducir un auto no
existirían las zapatillas ni la pasta
dental ni el desodorante ni los lentes
de contacto de las carreteras asfaltadas
ni los neumáticos ni la maleta con
rueditas y los perfumes ni el lápiz
labial ni los lentes de sol ni el
detergente del enjuague bucal ni la
crema hidratante y las prótesis dentales
y las camisetas deportivas de la
afeitadora desechable de la media de
nylon y las joyas y el gel para el pelo
y el esmalte de uñas del bloqueador
solar y el paraguas y las bolsas de
basura ni las válvulas cardíacas ni las
aspirinas las drogas para el cáncer y
los fertilizantes ni los preservantes de
alimentos en los vasitos de tecnopor el
lubricante sexual ni las vitaminas en
cápsulas ni el cemento en el cepillo de
dientes en el champú
y las mangueras de fotográfico y el
jabón del tinte para el pelón y los
bolígrafos ni la tinta de los libros en
las máquinas de rayos x en las botellas
de agua mineral y las flores
artificiales normal telas y las
alfombras el pegamento de las pelucas de
los fueron de los extintores del chaleco
salvavidas ni la dinamita y las pestañas
postizas ni la tapa del inodoro en los
vinilos ni los audífonos ni las bañeras
de los botones de la camisa y el papel
higiénico ni los condones
y casi todo lo que está hecho de
plástico desde piezas de naves
espaciales hasta una barbie desde los
balones de fútbol hasta cualquiera de
los casi 3 billones de smartphones que
hay en el mundo como el que os van cuñas
y niño bajo un pensaba comprarse con el
dinero que los ingenieros de petroperú
le habían prometido por su balde de
petróleo
era de noche cuando osman y sus hermanos
regresaron a su casa de madera al verlos
mamá lo regañó por haber salido sin
permiso entonces corrieron al patio
donde tienen la ropa y cacarean las
gallinas intentaron quitarse el petróleo
del cuerpo con agua con jabón pero no
pudieron usar un lavavajillas y no
resultó se restregaron la cara los
brazos las piernas con una escobilla y
detergente para ropa pero nada
hasta que un primo que también había
estado en el río les dijo que se
limpiaran con gasolina de motocicleta
esa noche
osmay no pudo dormir bien por la picazón
y el ardor de tanto haberse restregado
el cuerpo a la mañana siguiente los
ingenieros de petroperú volvieron a
nazaret en sus 4x4 el aire todavía
prestaba gasolina una treintena de
vecinas awajún esperaban con sus baldes
llenos de petróleo al lado de la
carretera les habían ofrecido 150 soles
por cada recipiente pero al final y a
pesar de los reclamos de la gente
los ingenieros sólo pagaron 20 soles
osman recuerda que un ingeniero le
pregunto su edad anotó su nombre en una
libreta y le dio dos soles como propina
por el balde que había juntado
le dijeron a osman
que el balde tenía más agua que petróleo
osman cuyo nombre significa el que es
dócil como un pichón no protestó como
otros niños cuando volvió a casa le dio
una moneda a su mamá y con la otra fue
con sus amigos a comprar una pepsi y
unas galletas de animalitos
cuándo
terminé de escribir esta historia
de lo que le pasó a guzmán y a su
familia
pensé muchísimo en mi responsabilidad de
mi condición de consumidor y de
ciudadano
pensé muchísimo en como muchas veces o
cuán perverso es el sistema de que
vivimos
en como muchas veces pasamos por el
mundo pasamos por la vida inundados en
petróleo y no nos damos cuenta
recuerdo que hace un tiempo escuché
decir a una periodista de lima muy
conocida
le decía a un dirigente indígena que
reclamaba la protección de sus
territorios le decía yo no me voy a
quedar sin luz porque ustedes no quieren
dialogar
fue muy simbólico para mí porque
revelaba muchas veces esa visión en sí
misma y centralista de que no quiere ver
el costo real de su foco encendido de
luz
ese costo no es el recibo que pagamos
cada mes en el banco oa través de
celular ese costó muchas veces es una
cadena de hechos y consecuencias que
ocurren muy lejos de aquí de este
auditorio sucede en las montañas donde
hombres mujeres y niños libran batallas
silenciosas
batallas que dejan muchas veces heridos
muertos desplazados
es un costo que no nos atrevemos a mirar
porque nos resulte incómodo
a veces pienso si no sería mejor vivir
en un estado de ignorancia
si a veces no sería mejor
no saber que esas cosas pasan
pero entonces recuerdo que el periodismo
es necesario precisamente por eso
es necesario para romper para destruir
ese muro de indiferencia que todos
levantamos dentro y construir puentes de
empatía hacia el otro para ser más
humanos para darnos cuenta
que nuestras vidas que están conectadas
a las de los demás
el que ustedes queridos amigos lean
historias como los de goldman tal vez no
a que el mundo sea un mundo mejor tal
vez haga que las cosas cambien
pero de lo que estoy seguro es que algún
momento esas historias los van a mirar a
ustedes a los ojos y les van a decir lo
que tengan que decirles yo no tengo
manera de saber que van a hacer ustedes
con esa información
pero el periodismo consiste también en
abrazar esa pequeña intuición y creer
que algo pasará
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]